four seconds between shot clock and game
clock well here he is jumping to the rim
on a beautiful move by the third-year
Pro and a Louisville Utah five with
James in transition look at Mitchell on
the emphatic rejection calmly got bound
by Bradley no call and Wow
it's a hot potater and nobody wants it
but Mitchell says fine I'll finish it
back into the picture this is the easy
deuce for LeBron but doesn't quit on
take them again soon step-back three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the third quarter the highest so far
this season
and if there was a time for Tatum to
find his jumper it would be now all
right here we go
smart looking looking for Tatum gets it
in
[Applause]
a lot of fun no question look at this
shot I mean no space to work
the game at 3:00 you wanted to but look
at JC tail
wastes no time at all spins out of
throwing life is the back on the Eagle
shot clock at three
shot clock to diamond take the shot and
that's why Donovan is a budding star
with 24 on the jump shot charlie baby
beautiful he went up high the paint
clear he took advantage met eight for
eight 18 points nine rebounds
Conley's dished out four assists and the
Jazz are ruling and how about that
high-flying Donovan Mitchell I love it
Donovan 78 61 Utah Minnesota still just
three of their last 11
goes up a shot on the right side at
midcourt Spain is that good enough
I'm not quick 26 Donovan just rolling
with Mitchell here with the three-point
shot all over him right away and he has
been just a great fit though some
defense with another three-point tatum
drives George right there
[Applause]
the inbounder is grant Williams who they
trust late-game so Marcus smart just
hands-off I wouldn't mind seeing that
again like they're making that live it
looks to me initially like their feet
get tangled that's exactly what happened
to me Paul falls because their feet get
tangled
boom shooting at the double-team but his
team was beaten by 48 in Dallas on
Wednesday night Joe flies it out to
Dante touch past battling 50 clock
downtown I start by the Warriors they
put up 28 against Yuto
[Applause]
put it home did he do it type moment he
gets up and puts it right on the face of
Mele posterized stare down
welcome to ESPN scooch if I take him
under the gun as the clock was winding
down three to shoot potato step back top
three Walker trying to get free its
Tatum with two Tatum for three
Jason Tatum with his third three of the
game he's got 15 to lead the Celtics
building Tatum says it's my turn with
the sidestep and fade away three have
him step up and be that vocal leader is
huge we rely on his presence in
particular when he has nice like he had
in Memphis we feed off that Oh KK you
saw it beautiful don't really without
hair styling I've been coming off whoa
that's an angry dunk a little bit see
the cross behind the back and then go up
angry dunk it
well the blender was going boys takes a
shot without a Mitchell man he just
takes off timing this just perfect with
the left-handed slam see what happens
inside the house Don the Mitchell going
to the roof right here des needed that
one well that's just a beautiful
defeatist even humans makes the call
it's potato looking behind the screen
one-legged bin range is good a nice way
to end the quarter for the Celtics who
nodded at 29 after 12 minutes what do
you make of what they've done since that
time well I thought the demand early on
in this guy's a legit star players Brad
Stevens not afraid
picks the pocket a young auto-hide law
pass Oh Donna but behind the back to go
bear beautiful beautiful play since a 23
22 score late in the first quarter a
thing of beauty
and the Jazz lead by one
[Music]
so gifted mentally the pump-fake happens
and then he goes to the rim and when he
is in flight watch out he's gonna try to
dunk it on you
check out the bench causing the defense
not to have as much energy on that in
just a 35-point 1/2 first of all no
one's gonna try to challenge look at
Germany's thinking about he says once
Donovan gets in the air no way
but you've loved the foot action of
Donovan when he gets in the air he's so
hypo though that he's able to kick his
legs out it's almost like what Jordan
used to do and he brought that to the
NBA take a step back nothing but water
jay-z Tatum's
at the twenty four point he's right
there on him and look at the little
step-back right there
get extra space and fundamentally sound
when you go reach you reach with the
hand the guy's driveling with you don't
reach to the opposite hand which will
stop and go drive spins beat the clock
how about this shot Mattie
beautiful shot here's another look on
the spin and the hang time to follow AJ
313 to play tap number one you talk by
three Roger over gets all the way to the
basket for two with five tips in a
second on the clock
Tatum trying to leaves done does for the
ball
[Applause]
you couldn't have played this any better
offensively in his hair space clock
running down no rhythm Tina
fines away knocks it down good time for
half time for the jazz angles gives it
up Donovan Oh banks it home that's gonna
count at the end the first half we see
the quick replay yeah definitely good
accounts what awareness by Donna knowing
a cool spot went to the bottom of the
backboard kept alive
[Applause]
a three-point lead believable trading
buckets right in the left long three
pumped up by Turner the Jazz come out
with it boy so Neal may be banged in
knee inside
[Applause]
is interesting Union looking at the
numbers they have only one win on the
road against them over 500 team Jason
bring that slow then this is just a
great move I BG I yeah I'm my shoulder
the rotating man would not get there in
time and I'm going strong I'm going to
use my for Williams to Tatum state him
on the drives nearly stripped left him
with a sweet move as the third quarter
comes to an end
watch that's Carter Williams Gamble's
then you have the guy coming for the
shot clock
Clarkson feeling it on a wall
Michell
Donovan Mitchell gets up higher than the
rest
look at him kick his legs out incredible
athletic ability catches just finishes
at the rim
[Applause]
this way to Tatum for of the shot clock
Hayden's gonna shoot it
[Applause]
clock was winding down fancy dribble and
the step away works he's got that one
down for Donovan Mitchell working
against Hardaway boy Sunil with a
headband on tonight Donovan out front
shot clock runs down to five one-on-one
the hand is up the shot is away and down
it goes
Donovan lose picked up by Gobert that
takes a glance of the shot clock down to
four down to three he'll jump it up in
you know what a big time shot by the
first time all-star there's O'Neal in
the paint double-team you're broody and
the Jazz have to pass out multiple times
and have to rush
here's Donovan look at the shot clock
going down 3-2 about 6 feet outside the
three-point line double post field goal
but Boston lead is down to 2 Tatum off a
try
[Applause]
believe that was Tatum with the pass
there here's this deal by Tatum and the
assists you are correct it is Jason
Taylor mother gorgeous pass winding down
he checks it under six
Michael Holly and Tommy have the
halftime show next great very quiet
hardened takes on Mitchell turns him
around
Tucker Falls and
this is an amazing play little crossover
double cross one hand gets fouled by
Tucker gets up like he's a man on a
mission
Rey jumps out on Joe trying to find his
three-point range Flags it off to
Donovan short shot clock takes a long
three just beat the horn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's Mitchell with two to choose gets
all the way to the rim and lazy
actually what he said that he needed to
do it shoot around this morning to get
going rather than try to go for a fire
deep three just get an easy bucket
losses and I'm playing bad then it's on
me
here's Donovan on the dunk he's got
spring in his legs me gets those two
legs together he's more of a two-footed
jumper than one that springs in those
legs man hmm
but taking ownership of when you're
playing bad VJ Tonka one of the top
defenders on this team hey this is it
right now he looks like a macho Jason
Tatum a step-back three you might think
he's shooting every time he touched it
vans picks it off
ahead to Sexton drives to the basket
great Rock chases it down and two at the
shot clock kind of shooters
inside outside shot clock running down
nobody was dead this is another short
short time to toss one up again Batman
gives it away gets it right back on it
cut it inside tough shot off the glass
and scores it best in the NBA on these
corner threes you see Mitchell shot
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content